Bower bird males are the kings of interior
design.
The put a great deal of effort into creating
the perfect ‘female friendly’ space.
But - these love spaces don’t always last.
Bowerbird bachelors can be intensely competitive
with one another in order to secure the affections
of the ladies.
After all, there’s only so much love to
go around...
There are twenty species of bowerbirds, and
these are primarily located in tropical areas
of Australia and Paupa New Guinea.
Males build bowers using sticks and small
branches, and they decorate them to a potential
females’ delight!
A wide variety of environmental objects can
be used in this way, including shells, stones,
berries, flowers or even human-derived objects
like bright colored plastic, cutlery or glass!
Why all the show?
Bowerbirds display a reproductive system called
‘resource-based polygyny’.
This means that males don’t really provide
anything to the female except for sperm.
The best way for a female bowerbird to decide
whose sperm to select comes down to the beauty
of the bower, and only the most beautiful
bowers win the attention of the females.
In addition to carefully designing and constructing
their own bowers, males engage in something
called ‘marauding’ behavior, where they
attempt to destroy and loot the bowers of
other males.
In some species, bower destruction by competing
males is a daily occurrence.
Any time a male leaves his own bower, he’s
risking the chance that another male will
come along and destroy it.
And if a male destroys a fancy bower of another
male, it’s a double win for him (since his
competition’s love nest is destroyed AND
he can take the decorations for use on his
own love nest.
All’s fair in love and war!
Actual mating takes place when a female approves
the males’ bower.
She comes to mate with the male in his cushy
pad, but she doesn’t stay.
Once she’s received her sperm selection,
she will build her own nest in which she will
lay her eggs and take care of her chicks when
they hatch.
She will be a single parent from here on out,
as the boys continue on their own quests for
the most beautiful and enticing space for
the ‘next good thing’.
Want to see more animal videos?
Check out this playlist from our friends at
The Dodo.
Don’t forget to subscribe to Seeker, and
be sure to keep coming back for more videos.